[Music]
this video is sponsored by macpaw
ooh okay all right now we're working hey
what's up guys mkbhd here and today
was apple's online only
2020 the worldwide developer conference
where they of course typically have a
lot to say about
software there's sometimes some hardware
surprises there was no hardware this
year but
they did have some good announcements
there's some cool new features and
there was a bigger a bigger announcement
at the end but first can i just say
as a video nerd the production
was a plus i was kind of wondering
leading up to it how would apple do
an online only wwdc keynote
you know they've been the gold standard
for live events for years and we've seen
that excellence but
now that they can't have people there
will they still do it on stage like that
but with nobody clapping would it be
kind of awkward but they nailed it
essentially it was a pre-recorded
presentation so
it was a little more dynamic with some
varied locations around apple campus
uh some variety of presenters same style
but they kept up the pacing and kept
down the awkward jokes and they still
got to flex their production muscle a
little bit with some pretty wild
over-the-top but still tasteful
transitions
thanks to some drone work i don't know
if the apple team watches these recap
videos ever or even cares what people
think of it but
bravo bravo so it started it kicked off
with
ios 14. and there's some new features
and some fresh new looks and there was a
sort of a
theme to it uh don't worry you'll pick
up on it so first off in the iphone
there's what's called the app library
basically an app drawer that's organized
by categories
recently added etc helps you see
everything in one place instead of
having to swipe swipe swipe
through all of your pages of apps and
what i thought was nice is now
since you have that all app view you can
actually hide
some of those extra pages of apps that
you don't need just
sitting over there so you go into what
they called i swear they called it on
stage
jiggle view i just go into jiggle mode
and then tap the dots at the bottom
and then just uncheck the pages that you
don't want to see anymore nice
then they also added widgets to the home
screen so they're taking them out of the
today only view
on the side and you can put those
widgets
anywhere on your home screen well
actually not quite anywhere on the home
screen i still think they're pinned
to the top so you can't truly put them
anywhere on the whole grid like free
placement
like a certain other os with widgets but
nevertheless
widgets are welcome they're rich they
have plenty of information in them plus
there's this new smart stack widget
which
essentially changes what widget it is
throughout the day
so it starts off as like your calendar
widget in the morning but through the
day as things happen
or as it knows what you want to do it'll
switch to your news briefing during the
day
or maybe turns into a summary of your
fitness activity in the afternoon like
hey
get a workout in so home screen
customization
an app drawer widgets on the home screen
just stop me if you've seen this before
they also added picture-in-picture video
support much more generally and that's
something that's been sorely missed for
a while in ios
that's been in other os's and then siri
has a ui overhaul it's not full screen
anymore but it's a much smaller portion
along the bottom of the screen now you
know kind of like the google assistant
with
i don't know it's kind of like android
crawled so iphone could run but for real
siri should have
way more answers in her knowledge graph
now so she can hopefully answer way more
questions
instead of just telling you here i
looked that up for you or here's what i
found and then there's a few more things
like a new translate app that they're
adding
which will hopefully let you have
conversations back and forth
in different languages you know if only
there was some other
industry standard translate app i could
compare that to okay i'll stop
um and then there's also something
called app clips and they basically let
you interact with small parts of apps
that you don't even have installed
and it'll plug into apple pay and sign
in with apple and everything else
and you can really quickly do stuff that
you couldn't do
without that app and they've made it
easy for developers to build in reminds
me a lot of okay
androids instant apps basically the
theme of course is
we're going to see a lot more overlap
with these two mature os's ios
and android it's just funny that so many
of these
new features in ios 14 have been around
since like the beginning of android
but that's not to say there weren't some
other features that weren't in
android and hey maybe they should copy
these features in the messaging app for
example you'd be able to
pin conversations to the top and they
added inline replies
in group chat and mentions in a thread
so you can have a group chat that only
sends you notifications when someone
mentions your name
kind of like slack that's pretty sweet
apple maps has now added a couple new
countries
and a dedicated cycling mode for when
there's bike routes
and also a new ev routing mode where it
knows
once you tell it what type of electric
car you have and then can route you
along
the way where you have compatible
chargers for your car
that's something google maps should add
and then underrated carplay gets a nice
fresh ui
overhaul with wallpapers a good
wallpaper just really sets your mood for
the day not gonna lie but maybe the most
impressive demo of them all was using
the iphone as
car keys so the first car that's going
to be compatible with this is the 2021
bmw m5 which they had there and there
will be more cars in the future
compatible with this but it will
literally use nfc to turn your phone
into your car keys to unlock the car and
then dock it
and start up and drive away which on one
hand is like oh great okay if i lose my
phone
now i also lose my car keys but on the
other hand
if i lose my phone i was already losing
my wallet
my phone my camera my communicator
i might as well add car keys to that
list i guess so then next up was
ipad os 14 and that got a lot of the
same
improvements you saw with ios so the new
widgets with the customizations
siri is now in the bottom corner so
again it's not taking up the whole
screen to tell you that it's going to
look for something now when calls come
in they don't take up the entire screen
too
just another small notification thank
god
and there's a smaller universal search
bar you know it's a lot of the same
stuff we saw
with the iphone but some of the next
level stuff came with the apple pencil
so scribble lets you hand write in any
text field
and any text you write or take notes in
will automatically be converted to text
that you can then
copy and paste into other places and
search with universal search
super powerful ocr really useful kind of
similar to what we saw with the galaxy
note
but of course now it's all on your ipad
and the iphone
and the mac another fun one you can draw
a simple shape
and then pause at the end and it'll
automatically draw a perfect version of
that shape one thing that i tweeted
about during the keynote that i think
got a lot of attention but it's it's
really one of those examples of why
apple's
ecosystem is so important to them is
because they have this integration where
it's a new airpods feature and if you're
listening to airpods and you have your
iphone out it can
tell now with ios 14 when you put down
your iphone
and pick up your ipad and it'll switch
your airpods audio
straight away to whatever you start
doing on that ipad
and if you put down the ipad and start
using the mac it'll know that too and
switch your audio
all of that automatically that's the
kind of stuff you look forward to oh and
another one of those things that sort of
slept under the radar but it was on that
slide that they put at the end of some
of the sections where there's some stuff
they didn't get to talk about
and that is you'll be able to set a
default email
and browser app on the ipad and the
iphone
finally again this has been something
you could do on
other os's but hey gmail as a default
chrome as a default you can now actually
do that thank you i'll probably do a
sort of a roundup of the best features
of
ios 14 and ipad os 14. the betas are out
now
you can grab them right now i probably
will as soon as i'm done shooting this
but similar to what i did with android
11 maybe leave a thumbs up below if
you're interested in seeing
a video like that i feel like a lot of
people are just interested in seeing how
the widgets
will actually work but let's move on
because they moved on to
watch os seven this is a there's a
lighter update they have some new
features you can now do
watch face sharing so you can share via
messages to contacts or to social media
if you want to share your watch face and
you can now do multiple complications
from one app which is nice but it's
still
not a totally custom third-party watch
face like we want oh and there's also
now
autumn this is the most 20 20 thing ever
automatic
hand washing detection as you start
washing your hands it
hears with the microphones the sound of
soap and water
and will start a countdown timer and
won't stop until you get to 20 seconds
encouraging you to wash your hands
properly
this is one of those things we're going
to look back at like wow what a time to
be alive but the biggest feature
for sure on the new apple watch os is
sleep tracking this is something we kind
of wondered about since the apple watch
first came out it's one of those big
features other fitness bands had
there's now going to be sleep tracking
on the apple watch which brings up the
question
when do you charge it and i think the
answer unofficial maybe officially but
the answer is in the morning
so if you wear the apple watch all day
you typically get about two hours of two
days of battery life with it
so you wear it all day then you wear it
all night it tracks your sleep the
screen is off
it can wake you up with a haptic
vibration so you don't wake up other
people around you
and then you charge it like briefly for
like a half an hour in the morning
and then you put it back on and you
start your day with a full battery i
think that's how it should work or you
could just
not have it track your sleep if you're
not into that alright the biggest update
in my well many people's opinions but
the biggest update from wwdc
mac os big sur so this is mac os
11. i don't know if you caught that
during the keynote but we've had mac os
10.x.x for a while now
this is mac os 11 and it is the biggest
change
since mac os 10 basically started and
it's
it's it's mostly a design overhaul and i
have mixed feelings about it because i
like some of it
and i just don't like some other parts
remember when i said a good wallpaper
sort of sets your tone for the day
i think i think the new wallpaper kinda
i'll link it below
sure i think it kind of masks some of
the things
that i don't like so much first of all
there's way more rounded corners
way more transparency with windows and
menus
way more variation in textures i don't
like the rounded corners on everything
but i'm cool with the rest of that then
there's a new dock with new icons and
this i have to do a double take at
i do not like a lot of these new icons
and i think it's something about the
shading or the shadowing
that they added the uniformity in size
that is great
but just looking at like the icons by
themselves like the finder icon
the facetime icon i just i don't know
looks kind of weird to me maybe let me
know what you think
i don't hide my dock you can't see it
over here but it's always on the side
there
and you know this is probably one of
those things we'll get used to in like
two weeks of having it but
maybe this will make me finally hide my
dock
i don't know looks kind of weird but
there's also a new quick settings and
notification center
that really struck me because it really
looks like it's modeled after the ipad
which also makes it feel like it would
work better with touch
than a mouse now i don't use the
notification center
in my daily use that often but the
inspiration here is pretty clear
and that is a big change for people who
actually do use this
often but again most of that is visual
changes but that brought us up to
the big announcement which is the big
transition so apple did in fact use wwdc
2020 to announce that they will be
transitioning
the mac from intel silicon
to apple's own custom silicon
this isn't really a surprise we sort of
saw this churning in the background and
we knew it was coming but it's a big
deal you see apple has had
their own silicon in some of their
products for a little while now it's in
the apple watch
but we've seen the type of impressive
performance they can get out of
an iphone pretty good then we saw
the type of impressive performance they
can get out of an ipad best in class
better than a lot of laptops so now
we're expecting to start seeing the type
of performance we can get
out of the thermal architecture of a
laptop
and a desktop now there's upsides to
this and downsides
the upside is of course with their own
chips in these devices
you can expect next level performance
that you can unlock and it's also
clearly a huge advantage for apple to
control their own destiny when it comes
to performance updates and features
instead of waiting for and relying on
intel but on the other side of the coin
there now has to be a transition period
because as a developer i mean this is a
developer conference
you now have this choice weirdly between
optimizing for intel max or optimizing
for
apple silicon max whatever they call
them because for a while
these two things will both exist at the
same time
now apple talked about this at length on
stage this is why they talked about
smoothing it as much as possible with
xcode and a universal binary that works
on both
intel based max and apple silicon but
there's probably a brief moment in time
where some apps work better on intel
and some apps work better on apple's
chips and you have to make your choice
of which mac to buy accordingly now
craig federighi on stage said he expects
this transition period to last about
two years seems reasonable and he also
said
that they still have some more intel max
in the pipeline coming up
and to also expect the first apple based
mac what is it called apple silicon
based mac
the first one of those will be coming
out by the end of this year 2020. but
yeah i'm super curious what sort of
things
that will unlock for apple as far as
performance when they make their own
ships like i'm imagining in a couple
years
a mac pro just being so sick having
all the thermal headroom in the world or
even just a macbook pro that doesn't
thermally throttle because
they're so much better at that
architecture than intel has been but you
know what that
is about it that wraps it up for what we
saw at wwdc
again we'll take a second look at those
features in ios and ipad os
but fun fact we'll also be having craig
federighi
as a guest joining me on the waveform
podcast
this week so i will ask leave in the
comments below what you want to ask what
you want us to talk about
what sort of clarification or specific
questions you might have and craig and i
will talk about it until then thanks for
watching
catch you guys in the next one and shout
out to macpaw for sponsoring
this video so with as much good as apple
does with mac os
it can still build up imperfections over
time and it does need maintenance so
that's where their product
clean my mac x comes in it helps you
stay aware of all the apps and services
installed on your mac
and all your permissions so you can
figure out which programs have access to
things like
your camera and your microphone and it
gives you more control over apps and
their files helping you free up space
and the most popular feature smart scan
helps you find logs and cache files that
are no longer needed
and get rid of them thus cleaning up
your mac so i'll leave a link below to
check it out for your mac
and thanks again to macpaw for
sponsoring this video
catch you guys in the next one peace